bienvenidos veamos el problema 124 según
un reporte de ventas de autos un tercio
del total de las ventas en cierto
período fueron sedanes y una quinta
parte del resto de los autos vendidos
fueron vagonetas si en la vagoneta se
vendieron durante este periodo cuantos
se dan es en términos de n se vendiera
no dicen que una tercera parte del total
de las ventas fueron se danés
edades y además nos dicen que una quinta
parte del resto de las ventas que si se
vendió una tercera parte de sedanes nos
quedaron dos terceras partes
de este total
en vagones
nos dicen que se vendieron n vagonetas
en este periodo así que estás vagonetas
también serán nuestra n vamos a despejar
t de esta primera ecuación y nos queda
que el total es igual a 3 por el número
de serán as 3 por s sustituimos esto en
la segunda ecuación y nos dice que es un
quinto por dos tercios del total que el
total encontramos que son tres por la
venta de sedanes es igual a n
este 3 se va con este 3 me quedan dos
quintos de ese dos quintos de s
igual a n
voy a despejar ese por lo que voy a
multiplicar ambos lados por 5 medios me
queda que s es igual a 5 medios de n
es nuestra opción de
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 125 7 / que es menor a 1 y p y q
son enteros positivos cuál de los
siguientes deberá ser mayor k 1 el que
nos digan que p entre q es menor a 1
indican que p va a ser menor que q y
como ambos son positivos pues no
tendremos que ver con cantidades
negativas si esto lo dividimos entre p
nos va a quedar que uno es menor que q
entre pp y eso tiene sentido porque por
ejemplo si yo tengo que un medio es
menor a 1
pues 2 entre 1 va a ser mayor que 1
si tengo 2 entre 3 menor a 1 pues tres
medios va a ser mayor que 1
y sorpresa aquí está la opción que entre
p y esta es nuestra opción
esta es nuestra opción solución esta de
acá veamos el siguiente problema
número 126 a una máquina le toma 4 horas
terminar una orden grande y a otra
máquina le toma 3 horas terminar la
misma orden cuánto tiempo les llevará a
más máquinas trabajando simultáneamente
ya sus respectivos ritmos terminar una
misma orden bueno ya hemos hecho
bastantes problemas de este tipo yo creo
que ustedes ya saben más o menos cómo
hay que resolverlos tenemos que la
máquina uno produce una orden en cuatro
horas
qué es lo mismo que se tiene una orden
la orden
entre cuatro horas o cada cuatro horas
y la máquina 2 esto es la máquina 1 la
máquina 2 va a producir una orden
la orden entre a cada tres horas
así que vamos a expresar esto de esta
manera un cuarto de orden por hora más
un tercio de orden por hora
esta es la rapidez combinada vamos a
buscar un común denominador esto es
igual a
3 x 4 12 3 x 1 3 + 4 x 14 y esto es
igual a 4 37 12 amos
esta es la rapidez combinada de estas
máquinas queremos saber cuánto se tarden
en terminar una orden tenemos la fórmula
de producción es igual a la rapidez por
el tiempo sabemos que la producción que
nos piden es una orden
tenemos que la rapidez son 7
doceavos de orden por hora y nos
preguntan el tiempo despejamos el tiempo
y nos queda que es 12 séptimos dos
séptimos
por la orden que es uno entonces esto
nos queda así como 12 séptimos de horas
o lo que es lo mismo
un entero cinco séptimos
de ahora para terminar una orden que es
mi opción sí
excelente veamos el siguiente problema
problema número 127 para enviar un
paquete la tarifa es de x centavos por
el primer kilo y 10 centavos por cada
kilo adicional y nos dicen que x es
mayor que y si tenemos dos paquetes que
pesan tres kilos y cinco kilos
respectivamente que se pueden enviar
combinados o por separado cual método
será más barato más barato y cuánto
dinero se ahorrará ok
nos dicen que x centavos cuesta enviar
el primer kilo
cuesta
centavos envías
kilo adicional
adicional
nos dicen que x es mayor que yo y los
paquetes que hay que enviar pesan 3
kilos y 5 kilos respectivamente
si los enviamos por separado pues para
el paquete de tres kilos vamos a tener
que pagamos x por el primer kilo más 2
que son 2 kilos adicionales
paga el paquete de cinco kilos vamos a
pagar x por el primer kilo más 4 james
por los kilos adicionales que son 4
adicionales
esto si los enviamos por separado
sumamos esto nos va a dar 2x + 6 y ahora
qué pasa si los combinamos sumamos estos
dos pesos y nos da 8 de aquí voy a pagar
x el primer kilo más 7 james por los
kilos adicionales que son 7 y de entrada
les puedo decir que el primer método es
más costoso porque de todos los kilos
que hay que pagar de los ocho kilos
combinados aquí hay una equis adicional
que es más cara que el ayer en cambio
aquí hay 710 que son más baratas que las
equis pero bueno vamos a seguir el
método lo que nos piden es vamos a
restar 2x menos pero más seis más se
dice que es lo que cuesta el primer
método de enviarlos por separado vamos a
ver la diferencia lo restamos con el
método combinado
+ 7 james hacemos la resta 6 -7 y va a
ser menos y 2 x x va a quedar como x x
menos x es mayor que tiene y el
resultado es positivo por lo que esta
primera opción como lo habíamos visto es
más costosa la opción combinada es la
más barata y nos ahorramos x menos 10
centavos
es mi opción
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 128 si se invierte dinero con una
tasa de interés r compuesto anualmente
la cantidad de invertida se duplicará en
aproximadamente 70 entre r años si los
padres de tomadas invirtieron 5000 en un
bono a largo plazo con un interés de 8
por ciento compuesto anualmente cuál
será el valor aproximado de la inversión
18 años después cuando tomás esté listo
para ir a la universidad
bueno veamos que tanto le lleva a
duplicar la inversión con un interés del
8 por ciento nos dicen que se duplican
en 70 entre r se duplica duplica
en 70 entre r&r aquí nos están diciendo
es 8%
vamos a hacer la división de 70 entre 8
entre 8 esto es 8 por 8 64 70 menos 64
quedan 6 1.08 por 7 56 61 56 queda 4
bajamos otros 0 8 por 5 es igual a 40 y
aquí nos queda la división exacta
entonces se va a aplicar cada 8 puntos
75 años casi cada 9 años entonces
tenemos que fueron 5.000 o 5k de
inversión inicial pasaron 8 puntos 75
años casi 9 años y esto se duplicó por
lo que aquí tengo 10 mil después pasaron
otros 8 75 años casi nueve años
para cuando tomas casi va a tener los 18
años aquí la inversión será de 20 mil
esos no son exactamente 18 años sino un
17.5 años que es lo más cerca que
llegaremos y es nuestra opción
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo